this morning we take a look at summer
hiring Trends it looks like it's getting
harder for many of you to find work a
recent LinkedIn survey found there's one
open job for every two applicants that
means more people are applying for fewer
job openings LinkedIn career expert
Catherine Fisher is here with more
trends that we can expect this summer
good morning good morning good morning
so is that surprising to you when you
look at where we were six months ago a
year ago that there aren't as many jobs
out there so historically we're actually
still a pretty good job market I think
when you're looking at the past it feels
maybe a little bit off and you're seeing
lots of headlines in the news about
layoffs but you know collectively it's
still a good job market for people yes
it is more competitive and there's two
things that are really contributing to
that one is that people are staying in
their jobs a lot longer so there's
internal Mobility happening and I think
also that they're seeing the headlines
and thinking you know I'm going to stay
put right the other thing is that
there's multiple people applying for
jobs more and probably jobs that they
shouldn't be applying for and so we're
seeing this from recruiters are saying
we're getting way too many applications
so it's just super competitive right now
but like you said I mean there is there
are jobs out there why are they applying
to jobs that they shouldn't be applying
for is it because they don't have the
degree requirements or the skill
requirements or it's just so easy these
days it's easy and I think just you know
not being very strategic about where to
hire but the good news is that in terms
of those skills we are seeing a
difference in terms of how companies are
looking at candidates and so it has
opened up new job opportunities for
people for example and marketing is a
great place to go if you don't have a
college degree it's a great Trend that
we're seeing with companies and so maybe
now we're seeing people are saying I
don't have a college degree I'm going to
start applying for these jobs that
perhaps before I wasn't qualified or
more companies saying that they don't
care so much about the college degree
and they're focusing more on skills is
that true that is true why do you think
that's happening well so really what
happened is during the pandemic
companies realized that there were
certain industries that couldn't hire
fast enough other industries were
shedding jobs so they started to re-look
at that Talent base of maybe it's not
about you know the school that they went
to or the industry that they're from but
can they do the job so that skills-based
hiring is really becoming popular what
about are you the AI I mean that's
that's like driving so many
conversations today yes AI is super
important it should not be scary and so
Microsoft did some research and 82
percent of the leaders said that their
employees are going to need to learn new
skills for AI so this does not mean that
we have to all know how to build it but
it does mean you should have some of
those Basics and it's simple to learn
like just understanding how to use a
prompt with chat GPT for example but
what's equally important are those human
skills the soft skills so where you
might ask you know chat gbt to help
build an agenda for your boss for a
meeting you know that your boss always
has this you know a particular thing
that she likes in her meetings where you
always start with a personal question
that's those soft skills the community
the leadership teamwork communication
we're running out of time here but
quickly for people who are watching us
at home right now and they want to keep
working from home working remotely that
is what are the industries with the most
remote openings yeah so Professional
Services have a lot of you know think of
like an architect those types of roles
have remote
um think of like Support Services
I.T media etc those do but I think that
is if you are looking for a job that's
fully remote just know that it's going
to be competitive and that Catherine we
might have to Circle back on this one
Circle back what do I say that works
hard for the money thank you